Welcome back to more of astronomy,
one 60,
uh,
the syllabus if you,
if you haven't got it yet,
is on the classes server.
Uh,
we have extra copies,
but I have to say I don't know where they are.
Uh,
and in any case,
everything that you need to know is on the classes server and there's actually
more than is on the printed syllabus there anywhere.
Uh,
let me say a couple things.
We're going to stick to the rule,
uh,
that there should be no science majors taking this class.
Uh,
and uh,
from the looks of the enrollment there's going to be no problem for juniors and
seniors.
I think we've got plenty of sections to accommodate everyone in here provided
you're not assigned to major,
but the way it's gonna work in terms of signing up for the class,
I think as I understand it,
is as follows,
a,
you need a section sections are mandatory for this course.
So you have to go through the online section signup process that'll start on
Monday,
but it will only start for freshmen and sophomores on Monday.
Uh,
juniors and seniors will be able to sign up for the course and sign up for
sections,
uh,
on Tuesday.
Uh,
and so please do that sections.
We'll start,
uh,
sections are going to be on Monday,
so they obviously won't start next week.
They'll start the following week.
Uh,
and uh,
but I have no doubt looking around the room that,
that,
uh,
we're going to be able to accommodate juniors and seniors if they want to take
the class.
All right.
Uh,
other things?
Yes.
The first problem set is a assigned as of today.
Uh,
when I get back to my office,
I'll stick that on the classes server as well.
Uh,
and you can pick it up from there.
It's do one week from today.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the way I like to do this as I like to have problem sets due at the start of
class because it bugs me to look out and watch people copying each other's
problem set.
Uh,
and so you have to hand it in at the beginning of class,
otherwise it's late.
Uh,
on the classes server,
there's a whole little thing about lateness policy,
which you ought to read.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
also something,
let me make a couple of general remarks about problem sets.
The purpose of problem set is different from the purpose of a take home test.
This is not something where the major purpose is to evaluate how much,
you know,
the point of problem set is to get you to actually do those particular problems
cause that's how one learns stuff in this kind of,
uh,
in this kind of subject matter.
It's kind of like doing the reading.
If you don't do it,
you're just going to have trouble.
Uh,
and so the reason it's a substantial fraction of your grade,
it's just to make sure that you do it.
Um,
okay.
So this has implications for working in groups.
Working in groups is strongly encouraged.
Please do that.
Uh,
it's a very good thing.
Make friends with the other people in the class,
work together,
talk to each other,
start early,
uh,
and uh,
you know,
may make use of each other's intelligence.
However,
at the same time,
uh,
we want to make sure that you actually do things.
So we want the work you hand in to be your own.
This sound contradictory.
On the one hand,
I'm telling you to work in groups.
On the other hand,
I'm telling you,
you have to hand in your own work.
What does that mean?
Uh,
and so,
uh,
as I,
as is written down on the classes server,
the way we,
uh,
try and work,
this is when you are actually writing down the thing,
you're going to hand in,
do that alone.
So if you work in a group,
figure out what you're doing,
get everything all set up,
then split up and write down the answer.
Uh,
because the process of actually writing the thing down yourself,
we'll make sure that you've actually understood what you,
what you were doing a,
and we'll check on this,
we'll look for it.
You know,
identical wording are identical multiplication mistakes and so forth.
Uh,
and so we'll keep a little bit of an eye on it,
but I do encourage you to work in groups.
Uh,
there's other ways of getting help.
If you need it.
Uh,
the primary source of help are the sections,
but of course those won't be meeting this week.
So not before.
The first problem set is due a office hours.
I'll be in Starbucks Monday from nine 30 to 11.
Please come,
uh,
and uh,
say hello and ask any questions you might have.
The teaching fellows are going to have a office hours on Wednesdays,
conveniently located the day before the problem sets are due.
You'll notice,
um,
and Oh,
let me strongly recommend,
don't send us email with questions about it,
uh,
since things into the forum on the classes server that way.
Uh,
and look first on the forum to see if somebody else has sent your questions.
this works really well.
We'll keep an eye on that all the time.
Uh,
we'll be answering it.
Oh,
not all the time.
Not probably after around eight o'clock at night on Wednesday.
If you have a question at two in the morning,
the day before something is due,
you're kind of on your own.
Yes.
Oh,
excellent question.
Thank you so much.
Uh,
morning,
I'm afraid.
Sorry.
Ah,
yeah.
I'm not as young as I used to be.
Um,
and Oh,
but let me say if,
uh,
if you do want to meet at some ghastly hour of the evening or something,
San be email,
uh,
we can,
we can find a time.
Same with the teaching assistants a sense stuff into the class of server at all
times.
We just don't guarantee you to look at it after eight o'clock the night before
to do start the problem sets early.
That way if you have a question,
you can answer it.
Not only that,
if you even just look at the problem set,
uh,
you know,
your brain will work on it in your,
in your subconscious and you won't freak out quite so much when you get past
midnight the night before it's due.
Um,
let's see.
Uh,
Oh yes.
In general,
I'm going to try and make it so that everything you need to know to do a
particular problem set has been covered in class by,
uh,
the day the problem set is handed out.
That would be today for this one in the very first week.
This week,
I'm not quite gonna make it.
And so there's one problem.
It's noted on the problem set.
It's,
there's one problem that you'll need stuff that I'll talk about on Tuesday.
There are going to be a bunch of help for various topics that are going to also
be linked to the class as surfers.
So,
uh,
by all means,
take a look at the,
uh,
at the problem set and start thinking about it,
as soon as you can.
Okay.
Uh,
let me remind you what we had started to talk about.
The class is organized into three,
a fairly specific topics,
the first of which is extra solar planets,
planets around stars other than,
than the sun exoplanets.
So called,
uh,
that's our topic.
And one of the things that I pointed out last time is that surprisingly enough,
very,
uh,
until 10 years ago,
none of these were known.
Uh,
and it's only a very recent development that there's any actual evidence that
these things exist.
Uh,
and so one question you might ask is,
why are these things so hard to find?
Uh,
the science fiction folks seem to have no trouble.
They just sort of go around in their space ships and find these things all over
the place.
Uh,
and uh,
to consider that question,
let me show you a picture.
Here's a picture of a star.
Uh,
this is the star Sirius.
It's the brightest.
It'll blow up obviously of a photograph plus a little photo shopped arrow.
That's not a celestial object.
Uh,
uh,
yeah,
so this is a blowup of a photograph of,
of the star.
Serious Sirius is the brightest star in the sky,
uh,
to then easily visible with the naked eye.
In fact,
as I say,
the brightest star,
uh,
it's one of the closest stars.
It's a little bit brighter than the sun intrinsically,
but you know,
it's 10 light years away or so.
Uh,
and let me comment on a couple of features of this picture.
First of all,
you can see the star covers a fair amount of area on this,
on this blown up picture,
but that has nothing to do with the actual size or shape of the star itself.
It's not like it's a big round ball with spikes coming off it.
That's not what's happening.
In fact,
if you had perfect optics and perfect vision,
uh,
this star would be a point,
and uh,
basically so small you couldn't resolve it right in the middle here.
That's the physical extent of the star at this scale is something like this and
you wouldn't be able to see you.
It all,
the reason it's extended is for two reasons.
First of all,
the atmosphere distorts a,
this was a ground based picture.
The atmosphere distorts how,
uh,
you see the star and in particular to like looking up from the bottom of a
swimming pool,
uh,
there's a distortion in the atmosphere and it makes the star seem to jump
around.
And so if you take an x,
a long photographic exposure of something,
the star has been jumping around during the exposure and,
and it smears out the image.
Uh,
plus also the optics of the telescope aren't perfect and these spiky things
here,
uh,
are due to the optics of the telescope is sort of a,
there,
there are all these spikes and that has to do with how one of the mirrors of the
telescope has held up.
Uh,
and so the combination of optics and atmosphere sort of spreads out the light by
a whole bunch.
This is always the case,
uh,
even when you're doing observations from space.
Now the,
uh,
the little Arrow here is pointing at a little bump,
a often the side,
but you might not have thought anything more of than you did about these spikes,
but in fact,
that's not a property of optics.
There's actually something there that's an object in orbit around serious.
And you might think that this is the way you would go about finding planets
orbiting other stars.
It would look kind of like this.
Here's a great big star.
There is a planet and if you watch this thing over a course of many years,
you actually see the position of this point move around.
It's because it's in orbit.
It's in about a 40 year orbit.
But here's the thing.
This isn't a planet.
It's another star.
This is a another star,
somewhat fainter than this.
A planet would be 10,000 times fainter than this thing,
but probably in about the same relative position to this.
Now,
picture all this light,
all this mess from this star and trying to find something right here that's
10,000 times fainter than this.
That's the problem.
The problem is that the,
the planets are relatively faint things that in itself isn't catastrophic.
We have big telescopes.
We can see pretty faint thing.
It's just their faith.
Things that are really near to things that are bright.
And so basically the problem with finding planets around other stars is the same
as trying to find a stars in the sky during the day time.
You,
why can't you see the stars during the daytime?
Because the background of the sky is much,
much brighter than the stars are.
Similarly,
uh,
if you had a little planet here,
you wouldn't be able to distinguish it from the atmospheric distortions and the
optical distortions caused by the telescope that takes this picture.
So the problem is you've got stuff that's fate near things that are bright and
the bright things have all kinds of distortions on them anyway.
And so you wouldn't be able to just to figure out what actually is a planet.
So,
uh,
just to summarize this,
the problem
is not that the planet to too faint,
although they are quick fade.
The problem is that the planets are too close.
Yeah.
To The star.
Uh,
okay.
And that prompts,
we've got to quantify this statement I think.
Uh,
and so the question arises,
well,
how close is it?
Uh,
and that leads into a discussion which we already started last time of planetary
orbits.
If you want to answer that question in any quantitative sort of wag a,
and you will recall that law,
uh,
in last class I wrote down an important equation of uh,
regarding planetary orbits that looks like this.
A cubed is equal to p squared.
M where this is the mass of the objects in orbit around each other in units of
solar masses.
This is the orbital period,
right
in units of years.
And this is,
uh,
orbit.
You will recall our ellipses.
Uh,
and this is the so called Sammy major access.
Okay.
Uh,
of the lips in units called astronomical units,
which is the distance from the earth to the sun or the semi major axis of the
earth.
Sun Orbit more properly.
So that's in a particular set of units.
Um,
okay.
Before going on,
let me make a couple of general remarks about equations.
First thing to say about equations is,
you know,
there's this idea that equation's mathematics is some terribly different
language.
Not at all.
Uh,
this is an English sentence.
Okay.
The sentence read a cube is equal to p squared times an period.
And if you wrote this down in a textbook,
you'd actually see,
they put the period in there.
Uh,
it's got a verb is equal to,
it's got a subject,
it's got an object.
Uh,
all this is,
is a different way of writing stuff down.
Uh,
so it's not a different language.
It's just a different writing system.
That's all.
So don't freak out.
That's the first thing.
It's,
it's just ordinary English.
Um,
the second thing to say is that this is a physics equation and not a math
equation.
And that's actually a subtler point.
You will recall back in eighth grade Algebra when they,
you know,
they started writing down x is equal to sump,
whatever x was equal to.
And they said,
you know,
the amazingly cool thing about Algebra is that x could be anything,
right?
That's why it's so powerful.
And so you can solve whole classes of problems all at once just by letting x
equals something unknown.
Uh,
that's math,
physics.
It isn't true.
It is not the case that this equation is true regardless of what a is or
regardless of what is,
this is only true for very specific meanings of those quantities.
And,
uh,
the amazing thing about the universe is it turns out that math equations apply
in very specific physical situations.
This didn't have to be true either.
That you could express physical things in mathematical equations and the math
and physics would have anything to do with each other.
Uh,
and it is different to have a physics equation then to have a math equation.
It's because it has to be so specific.
If you substitute something that isn't semi major axis in for a,
then that equation isn't true anymore,
it seems kind of obvious.
I know,
but,
but yeah,
it worth keeping in mind.
Uh,
the other thing is that physics equations tend to have units associated with
them,
not always,
but most of the time.
And so that's why it's so important to say,
well,
this is true not only if m stands for mass,
but also if the mass is expressed in a particular set of units,
uh,
in this case solar masses.
Uh,
you'll recall from last time that this is actually a specific version of a
slightly more general equation,
which looks like this.
Hey cubed equals p squared,
g m over four Pi Square where Ge is a constant,
uh,
that depends on what units you're using.
And,
uh,
last time I derived this equation from that.
Uh,
but another way of saying it is,
uh,
if you choose your units,
to be a solar masses,
uh,
years and astronomical units,
then,
uh,
g is equal to four Pi squared.
And so it cancels out.
That's another way of,
uh,
of thinking about why this specific version of the equation works out.
All right.
Uh,
so once you've got your physics equation,
what are you supposed to do with it?
Uh,
well,
the first thing you should do is,
is,
is take a careful look at it and figure out what kinds of problems you can
solve.
This again is,
is,
is fairly straightforward,
obvious stuff.
Uh,
if you've got a cubed equals p squared m,
there are obviously three different problems you can solve.
If you know a and,
m,
you can compute P,
right?
Eh,
if you know a and p,
you can compute m.
And if you know p and m,
you can compute a,
so,
you know,
two of these things,
you find out the third this problem aversion.
Oh,
an example of this problem we did last time,
we had,
uh,
we solve for the,
for the orbital period of Jupiter by knowing how far away from the sun it is and
what the mass of the sun is.
So like Jupiter last time.
Okay.
Uh,
so let's do another one of these examples.
Yeah.
Just quickly here.
Uh,
what is the mass of the sun
of the sun?
Uh,
so that's obviously this version of the problem.
and so what we're gonna do is we're going to take a and p from the Earth's
orbit,
use Earth's orbit to determine the mass of the sun.
And this is in fact how one goes about determining the mass of the sun.
So,
uh,
let's use this in the unit.
We have a is equal to one astronomical unit for the earth.
P is equal to one year for the son.
One cube does equal to one squared times m.
So M is equal to one in units of solar masses.
Okay.
Not Surprising,
right?
And,
and not particularly illuminated,
right?
Uh,
that,
that the mat at the mass comes out to the mass of the sun,
comes out to be one in units of solar masses.
Uh,
if we use a different set of units,
this is a more interesting calculation.
So let's use a more standard set of units.
This so called Mk ass units.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
meters,
kilograms for mass and seconds for time.
All right,
so now,
um,
turns out and astronomical unit is expressed in meters is a 150 billion meters
approximately and looks something like this.
Uh,
and what's a year expressed in seconds?
Well,
let's see.
A year is 365.24 days a day is 24 hours.
A an hour is 60 minutes and uh,
a minute is 60 seconds.
So that's a year expressed in seconds.
Uh,
and at this point we better pause and,
and,
and get our,
uh,
large numbers straight.
Uh,
you are all probably familiar.
I imagine with scientific notation,
this becomes very important.
Otherwise,
the Nem numbers as you can clearly see,
get,
get completely out of hand.
Uh,
and,
uh,
because it's so important.
I'm going to a tire you,
uh,
by uh,
writing down some fact about scientific notation.
There's a help sheet on this if you have any trouble.
Uh,
but uh,
recall how this works.
Uh,
you're supposed to express numbers as in the following form,
uh,
and times 10 to the Em,
this is,
uh,
a decimal with one digit out in front of the dot.
This is supposed to be an Integer,
a whole number,
either positive or negative.
Uh,
and uh,
the reason that this is easy to deal with is because of one of the great
limitations of the human brain.
Uh,
we only deal well with really small numbers,
basically one digit numbers.
If I take a a few coins here and I sort of throw him up,
you immediately know that there are four of them.
You don't have to count one,
two,
three,
four to satisfy yourself that therefore coins on the table because we have a
concept of foreignness all of us in our mind,
and it clear that this pattern satisfies that concept.
If I threw a two coins or six coins or seven coins,
you'll probably be okay.
If I through 13,
you'd start to have real trouble.
If there were 271 of them,
uh,
there's no way you could guess just by looking at them how many there were.
You'd have to count them one by one.
So the human brain really only deals well with one digit numbers.
And you can tell this because of the names we give to numbers.
When you start getting big numbers,
we call the millions or,
or a billions or trillions and they all sound alike.
That's because we can't tell the difference between a million and a trillion.
It's just big.
Uh,
and so anytime you get up into big numbers,
we stop and we start to completely lose our grip on what these numbers mean.
And you have to have elaborate metaphors.
You know,
a trillion is,
um,
uh,
is a million million.
And if you fill up the moon with ping pong balls there,
I don't know,
you know,
that you have to do that kind of mental exercise to get a grip on it.
The nice thing about scientific notation is that it turns big numbers into small
numbers,
right?
And is a number between one and 9:00 AM is an integer.
It's one of those numbers,
four,
five,
six,
that we can get our minds wrapped around.
Recall what this means,
right?
Uh,
tend to,
theM is one with m zeros after it.
Uh,
and so that's the point of scientific notation.
It's to take big numbers and allow us to,
to deal with them.
I think this is a really valuable thing and I kind of wish that budget
discussions in Poland in the political context would take place in scientific
notation because people are always making mischief from the fact that all big
numbers,
how delight you have a congress critters saying things like,
oh,
terrible disaster.
There's $1 million of waste in the Pentagon budget.
Okay,
the Pentagon budget is $500 billion.
$1 million of waste.
That's me dropping a nickel behind the couch on my budget.
Uh,
and so that's act and nobody would accuse me of being wastefulness if I didn't
move the couch and get that nickel out.
All right.
Uh,
and it's because a million sounds big and so does 500 billion.
And we have no real sense of what,
of how big these things are relative to each other.
But we do have a sense of the difference between six and 11,
which is the difference in scientific notation between $1 million and a hundred
billion dollars.
So,
uh,
that's how this works.
Uh,
so yes,
so arithmetic rules,
uh,
again,
there's a help sheet on this if,
if you're rusty,
uh,
if you have in times 10 to the m and you multiply it by another scientific
notation number a times 10 to the B,
uh,
that is equal to a times.
And,
and the other nice thing about scientific notation is it turns multiplication
into a ditch addition because the exponent add a times and two times 10 to the m
plus B.
Similarly,
if you take end times 10 to the m and raise it to the case power that's into the
k,
uh,
times 10 to the m times k.
So it turns exponentiation into multiple,
multiple occasions.
So the nice thing about dealing with exponent is,
uh,
it makes it one kind of arithmetic easier.
Uh,
and so a specific example of this might be an times 10 to the em,
the square root of that which is raising to the one half power.
This is equal to n to the one half times 10 to the m over to that works if
Amazon even number.
But if m is an odd number,
you get a crazy exponent.
This really has to be an integer over here.
So what do you do then you say and times 10 to the m to the one half is equal to
10 times and times and too the m minus one to them,
one half power.
So I've just moved a 10 from here over to here and then that is equal to 10 and
two the one half times 10 to the m minus one over two.
And that's how you recover,
uh,
when you,
when you take a square root or something like that,
that's how you recover a,
an integer on this side.
We'll have lots of practice in this kind of thing.
Uh,
okay.
So going back to the problem,
one,
a u is equal to 1.5 times 10 to the 11 meters.
Uh,
one year is equal to a 2.4 times 10 to the one that's 21 times six times 10 to
the one times six times 10 to the one times 3.6,
five two,
four times 10 to the two seconds.
All right,
so let's do that.
One,
two,
three,
five a 2.4 times six times six times 3.6 blah,
blah,
times 10 to the five,
two and a half times six is around 15,
15 times six is around 90.
90 is a little less than a hundred.
3.6,
a little more than six.
Those two things multiplied together as around 300.
Uh,
and 300 times 10 to the five is equal to three times 10 to the seven.
So there are around three times 10 to the seven seconds in one year.
That's a good number to remember.
Oh,
and in mks unit
and mks units,
gee,
this magical constant is something like seven times 10 to the minus 11.
Uh,
that's an approximation.
It's actually 6.6 something,
something,
something times 10 to the lunch slam,
but we'll call it seven.
So now we're in a position to calculate the,
see what the solar mass is in kilograms 1.4.
So remember a cubed equal to g m P squared over four Pi squared.
So let's say a 1.5 times 10 to the 11 that uh,
an astronomical unit cubed,
uh,
p squared,
three times 10 to the seven,
that's one year squared.
Seven Times 10 to the minus 11,
that g over em over four Pi Square.
All right,
I'm going to do the arithmetic really fast.
Uh,
I would like you to learn how to do that yourself rather than relying on
calculators.
So this is an example.
Let me blaze through this at warp speed.
Then we'll stop and consider what's happened.
All right,
uh,
on the right hand side,
let's see.
Um,
three squared is that's three squared times 10 to the,
uh,
seven times it's time to,
to is 14 times seven times 10 to the minus 11:00 AM uh,
over four times Pi Times Pi.
Uh,
three squared is 10,
10 times 10 to the 14 is 10 to the 15.
Uh,
and so on the top we've got 10 to the 15 times seven times 10 to the minus 1150
minus 11 is for,
so that's seven times 10 to the four on top.
Uh,
Pi Times Pi is 10.
That's 44 times 10 to the one on the bottom.
Seven divided by four is two.
And so that's two times 10 to the three times am all right.
Good ahead.
Lefthand side.
Uh,
all right,
one,
1.5 times 1.5 times 1.5.
That's 1.5.
Two Times 10 to the 33.
Why 33?
That's 11 times three.
Okay.
1.5 times 1.5.
That's a little bit more than two.
If you multiply something that's a little bit more than to buy something that's
a little bit less than two,
that's four.
Uh,
and so this is four times 10 to the 33,
and now we want em,
right?
So we got to divide both sides by two times.
10 to the three M is equal to four halves times 10 to the 33,
uh,
over 10 to the three.
That's 10 to the 33 minus three.
That's two times 10 to the 30 telegrams.
Got to put the units in.
Okay.
How are we doing questions,
comments,
use.
Yes sir.
How accurate is that number?
It's accurate to about one digit.
Uh,
which is why I only wrote down one digit of accuracy out front.
This is a pro.
Excellent question.
Thank you very much.
Uh,
this is appropriate because remember I'm using seven times 10 to the minus 11,
four g where to actually 6.6.
So I'm already a about 10% off from there.
I did my little calculation to come up with one year equals three times 10 to
the seven seconds.
That's about accurate to one digit or so.
Uh,
and Silva whole thing is done to one digit accuracy.
If you're dealing with one digit accuracy,
it is true that seven divided by four is two.
It really is true because if you,
if that wasn't true,
then you would have to have more digits on your unit for GE or something like
that.
Uh,
and in particular,
let me make an official rule for this course.
Three equals Pi equals the square root of 10.
All right?
That will solve an enormous amount of arithmetic problems and it will not get
you into any serious trouble.
So we don't have to worry about the 0.14,
one,
five,
nine,
and however many more digits you all memorized to.
Uh,
uh,
and when you multiply it together,
you get 10.
Yes,
yes.
So the question was,
am I expecting this kind of calculation for problem sets?
The answer is yes.
Here's the rule about calculators.
Let me put it this way.
Uh,
you can only use calculators if I can't tell that you've done it.
so you know that that means you can,
you know,
check your work to make sure you've done it right or something.
But if you start coming up with numbers,
like 7.15,
one six,
three,
nine,
seven a,
that's eight digits of accuracy.
And I'm pretty sure you haven't worked it out yourself.
Uh,
so you know,
and Oh,
uh,
important.
No calculators on the tests.
Okay.
So get some practice doing this kind of thing.
Uh,
and this will,
this I promise you will be useful,
useful to you in,
in everyday life because this is how you catch the politicians doing screwy
things with big numbers.
You do it in your head and in scientific notation and you figure out,
uh,
whether the answer is meaningful or not.
Um,
this whole business of significant digits I think is,
is badly distorted by the way it's taught in high school.
Uh,
in high school.
You and also I should say in,
in laboratory courses,
sometimes it's at the college level.
You often get situations where people say,
uh,
give you a whole sheet of rules on how to figure out how,
how many significant digits you have.
This is nonsense.
All you have to do is behave like a human being.
We say to each other,
you know,
I'll meet you in the dining hall in 10 minutes.
That doesn't mean that means something different from,
I'll meet you in the dining hall in 11 minutes and 26 seconds.
Even if the person happens to show up in the dining hall in exactly 11 minutes
and 26 seconds,
10 minutes means I'll meet you there in 10 minutes.
We all know what that means.
I'll meet you there at 11 minutes and 26 seconds means you're a character in a
bad spy novel who's just synchronized as watch.
Uh,
so,
uh,
this shows up.
It's science fiction to,
I don't know how many of you are star trek fans.
Uh,
I certainly am.
and in all the different and all the different star trek movie a snack you,
uh,
in all the difference a friend,
and all the different star trek movies,
there's always a second in command who isn't a human being,
right?
A volcan aren't android or,
or,
or some damn thing or another.
And to emphasize the non humanness of these characters,
what they do is they make them use too many significant digit.
Uh,
and so that makes them human.
And so I tell the captain will say,
when are we landing on omicron m and the second in command will say,
well,
we should assume Sant standard orbit in 2.6,
three,
nine,
five minutes,
uh,
emphasizing somehow superior brain power or something.
But it's nonsense because it takes the guy 10 seconds to say that sentence.
So what is this time,
you know,
calculated to a hundredth of a second.
Does it start from when he begins the sentence from when he ends the sentence?
Well,
what's the other end of that time interval?
Can you say,
you assume standard orbit,
uh,
to the 100th of a second.
What does that even mean?
Uh,
when you start beaming down,
when you end beaming down,
uh,
and also keep in mind,
it takes more than a hundredth of a second for the sound to travel from his lips
to the captain's years.
Saw the whole thing is just nonsense.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
you know,
you don't need any special rules,
just behave like a human being.
Don't behave like an android.
Uh,
and so no androids.
and that's the only rule I'm going to give you,
that these two are the only rules I'm going to give you about a significant
digits.
Just do the right thing.
Okay.
Um,
all right.
Uh,
okay.
So,
uh,
this is all,
this is all lovely,
but we haven't actually started to answer the question we started the class
with,
let me remind you where we began this disquisition on numbers.
Uh,
the question was supposed to be how far away from stars are planets?
so haven't answered.
We haven't answered the question when the question was how close are planets,
uh,
two stars.
This notation will confuse the people who didn't make it to class today.
That's probably just as well too.
All right.
How close to planets are planets to stars?
And now we have a problem because closeness,
we usually think of this as being measured with distances.
And,
uh,
distances are a serious problem in astronomy.
Supposing you,
uh,
distanced by the way is more or less the same thing as size,
right?
Size is the distance from one side of something to another side of something.
So,
uh,
so size and distance of the same.
So supposing you ask the question,
how big is the moon?
What is the size of the move?
What is the distance from one side of the moon to the other?
You go out one night and you look up at the moon and you do this one on each
side of the moon.
You say,
well,
it's about an inch and a half.
Okay.
Now obviously that's meaningless because if you had done it here,
it would have been about a half edge.
Uh,
and we all know that that isn't,
that somehow it is not the right answer.
Uh,
if you look at the screen over here,
for example,
and you hold out your hands about eight inches from your a closed one,
I hold out.
You can try this.
Hold out your hands about here.
You'll find that that screen,
the,
uh,
the lit part of the screens about four or five inches across.
But if you go closer to your eye,
it's only about an inch across.
If you're at arms length,
it's maybe six,
eight inches where I'm standing here.
And if you tried it,
the back of the classroom get a different answer from what I just got.
So distance is a problematical thing.
Uh,
and so,
but on the other hand,
obviously the size of the screen hasn't changed depending on where my arms were
or whether I'm standing at the back of the room or the front of the room.
So something has to be measurable there,
but it isn't distance when what it is is angle.
What you can measure in astronomy are angles.
So here's what you really want to know.
Here's a star,
here's a planet going around the star.
And here is you.
This is the international symbol for an observer.
It's supposed to be a little stylized eyeball.
Uh,
and okay,
so this observer is looking at this star planet system and looks at the Star and
looks at the planet.
And what you can measure is the angle,
which I'm going to call Alpha here.
And if you simulate the angle by putting your hands up close to your eye,
you'll get a small distance.
If you do it further away,
you'll get a bigger distance.
But what you're measuring is the angle a and what you would like is a way of
being able to convert from that angle into a distant.
And now the ugly specter of trigonometry rears its head because that's what
trigonometry is.
It's a way of turning angles into distances and vice versa.
And you may remember constructions that looked vaguely like this,
what's put some labels on it.
Here's distance one.
Here's distance to here's distance three.
Uh,
and uh,
this is the definition of sign.
The sign of an Alpha is equal to the opposite over the hype pot news.
So that's d two over d three.
Uh,
and now,
uh,
so that's how you do it.
Now,
I promised you on Tuesday that the ad that the sign was going to cancel out.
And so it is a,
here's how,
uh,
if you use small angles,
it turns out that the sign of Alpha is equal to Alpha.
If Alpha is expressed in Radians,
which is a particular kind of measure of angles.
And so,
uh,
for small and goals,
first of all,
the High Pot Newson,
the longer side are the same length,
more or less.
So you've got a situation like this where [inaudible] over d one is equal to
alpha.
That is,
uh,
let's circle that one in red.
It's going to be important.
Uh,
that's called the small angle formula.
And once again,
you have to be careful of the unit.
there's two sets of units in which you might possibly use this.
Uh,
uh,
so d two over d one is equal to alpha.
If d two and d one are in the same units,
then Alpha has to be in radiant,
uh,
a radiant dare.
Two Pi Radians inner circle,
two Pi Radians in a circle.
Uh,
you'll recall there 360 degrees in a circle.
That's how you convert from degrees to radiant.
Uh,
but there's a better set of units.
It turns out also that if you do this,
use this equation [inaudible] Alpha and d two is measured in astronomical units.
Remember those,
that's the earth sun distance and d one is measured in Parsecs,
uh,
which is equal to three times 10 to the 16 meters.
That's about three light years.
For those of you counting at home,
uh,
and Alpha is in arc seconds.
Then it also works out.
Let me tell you an arc second.
Let's see.
60 arc seconds is equal to an arc minute.
Just so you know how these units work.
60 are committed is equal to one degree.
So that's a,
a really small angle.
So it turns out this set of units is particularly useful for these kinds of
planet calculations because distances from planets to stars tend to be a few
astronomical units,
distances from us to the nearest stars.
The nearest stars turned just aside from the sun,
turns out to be about one parsec away.
So distances to stars are some number of parsecs.
Uh,
and so you'll get a answers that are,
you know,
a few arc seconds and this is yet another way of turning big numbers into small
numbers.
You use the right set of units so that everything's approximately one.
Uh,
another way of compensating for the weakness of the human brain.
okay.
So now we can solve a problem
we can actually solve numerically.
The question of how far away,
uh,
from a star is,
our,
uh,
our planet.
So here's an example.
Here's a problem of the kind that might show up on a problem set.
Uh,
I told you that that object orbiting Sirius has a about a 40 year period.
So let's take a planet,
uh,
with a 40 year period that's kind of between Saturn and Uranus in our own solar
system,
uh,
around a star three parsecs away,
PC means parsecs,
whatever they may tell you in the humanities classes.
All right?
Uh,
okay.
Around a star three parsecs away.
What is the angular separation?
Okay.
Angular separation because that,
uh,
what we can actually measure,
you can't measure the distance,
but we can't add,
measure the angle.
Okay?
So this is a hard problem.
Okay.
Why is it hard?
It's hard for two different reasons.
First of all.
Well,
you guys know how to solve problems like this.
You all went to high school.
Uh,
what you do is you say,
okay,
what do I know?
I have p equals 40,
I have d equals three.
I want alpha.
So I looked for an equation with d p d and Alpha in it.
I shove these two things into the substitute the man for p and d,
and then I calculate alpha.
And you don't have to actually know anything about anything.
In order to do that,
you just have to have a good set of notes and you go through all the different
equations until you find the equations,
the equations that contains all the variables you have and the one that you're
asked for.
And then you can just plug it in.
You don't have to know anything about anything.
This won't work,
right?
Because if you go through the lecture notes thus far,
you will not find any equation with P and d and alpha in it because it's two
different equations,
uh,
there that you have to put together.
And that requires you to actually know what you're doing.
Uh,
and that of course is much harder.
so plug and Chug won't work
and chug fails.
Uh,
because there's no one equation,
okay.
Uh,
this is a hard problem for another reason,
which is that I haven't told you something important.
If you try and go through and solve this,
you will discover it,
that you don't have all the information you need.
And in particular,
you need to know the mass,
the total mass of the system,
the mass of the star,
most of the masses in the mass of the star.
So there's missing information.
That's one way to make a problem hard.
The other way to make,
uh,
you know,
I don't tell you everything you need to know.
It's a somewhat harder problem.
Uh,
the other way to make a heart problem heart,
this is a classic that,
that,
you know,
be warned.
Uh,
I will do this at some point is to give you one extra piece of information that
you don't need this screw students up total.
Uh,
because,
uh,
you go looking for the equation that uses the extra piece of information and
there is no such an equation and you don't need it.
And then you,
then you're cast into doubt.
You know,
I,
I must need this somehow or he wouldn't have given it to me.
Uh,
nonsense.
You know,
in real life,
it is not the case that all problems come to you with all the information you
need and only the information that you need.
That's not how things work in real life and it shouldn't be how things work.
Uh,
in preparation for real life,
which is I guess what classes,
uh,
sorta ought to be a,
so missing information,
too much information.
Yeah,
sometimes,
although not in this case,
uh,
I could have told you the temperature of the star,
for example.
Uh,
oh,
I'll do that.
The temperature,
uh,
of serious is 10,000 degrees surface temperature.
Uh,
so now I've given you both.
I've,
I've left out information that told you too much.
All right?
So,
uh,
what is the mental process that you need to go through and solving a problem
which has these kinds of difficulties associated with it?
Okay.
So how to think about such problems.
The first thing to notice is,
uh,
what you would do in the ordinary plug and chug.
What have you got?
What do you need?
You have a value for the orbital period.
You have a value for the distance.
And what you want is an angle.
Uh,
okay.
Now then,
and so and so you know this,
this doesn't lead you to where you want to go.
The next thing you've got to do is make an assumption.
This is a star.
All stars are more or less the same.
So let us imagine that this star has a mass,
more or less similar to that of the sun.
So the AMA is approximately equal to a solar mass.
How far wrong could you go?
In fact,
you go wrong by about eight,
about a factor of two.
But at a certain point you're going to take the cube root of two.
Uh,
and so it actually isn't so bad.
so suppose m is equal to the mass of the sun.
Most stars are approximately.
Aha.
Now we're getting somewhere because now we have an NP.
And if you have put that equation and,
and,
uh,
Kepler's third law and interpreted it deeply into your brain and it has become
part of your heart and soul and very being,
you will immediately realize that if you have m and p of course you can
calculate,
hey,
and in fact,
you probably realize this first before you make the assumption in step two,
because that's why you're interested in the mass.
Because you realize that if you happen to have an,
you would be able to determine.
A next thing you have to do is interpret what this a is a,
is the semi major axis of the orbit of the planet around the star.
That's,
uh,
something,
very close to,
uh,
very similar to the distance,
between the star and the planet
is a,
so a,
is this a,
and this equation is the same as [inaudible] two in the other equation.
All right?
So a is d two and the distance you have up there is the distance from us to that
whole system.
That's d one.
And now you can compute
Alpha,
right?
That's the thought process.
Uh,
and you may have to go sort of worry a little bit or a little bit around here,
uh,
before you have the Aha moment of how to,
how to get the problem.
This is the moment when you've solved the problem.
And the key to solving this is to,
uh,
have an instinctive reaction to knowing that you've got a period.
Namely,
if I had a mass,
I could figure out the Emmy major axis,
or if I had the semi major access,
I could figure out the mass and that has to click.
And the way that clicks is to have this equation,
uh,
really,
I was joking before,
but a really become,
uh,
instinctive in a certain way and there won't be many equations in this class,
but it will really help you to assimilate them,
uh,
in,
that kind of depth.
All right.
Uh,
so now in the few minutes remaining,
let me actually solve this problem numerically.
Um,
P is equal to 40 years.
Uh,
D is equal to three.
Parsecs here's something not to do 40 times,
three times 10 to the seven,
because that'll give you the answer in seconds.
No,
don't do that.
Uh,
because both of the equations would rather have things in astronomical units at
years and things like that.
So a cubed equals p squared.
M A M is one by assumption.
Uh,
P is 40.
so this is 1600.
That's 40 squared on this side.
Hey Cube,
that's 1.6 times 10 to the three.
Now we're going to take the cube root of both sides.
That's the cube root of one.
Sit in 1.6 times the cube root of 1,003 times a third is equal to one.
Conveniently enough,
uh,
the cube root of 1.6,
oh,
I don't know,
that's 1.2 or something,
but call it one.
Uh,
so that's 10.
and so it's 10 astronomical units.
Remember the,
where are you doing this in solar masses years?
Astronomical Unit,
10 astronomical units.
That's how far away it is.
Now we can do this
where this is an astronomical unit.
Uh,
and this down here is in parsecs and 10 divided by three is three.
So the answer is a is equal to three arc seconds.
Yeah.
Now this is an important result because the,
uh,
let me go back to this picture.
The angular scale over which light is kind of thrown around by the atmosphere
and by the optics of the kinds of telescopes we can build is some number of arc
seconds.
Uh,
uh,
about half from good ground based observations,
maybe half the light is inside one arc.
Second,
the rest of the light is scattered all the way out to maybe 10 arc seconds from
space.
It's a little bit better.
But,
uh,
light from,
observations of stars
is scattered
over angular.
Yeah.
Sizes of some of arc seconds.
So you are guaranteed that there's going to be a bunch of light from the star,
right on top of where you're looking for your planet.
And in fact,
it's going to get worse because one of the things about this equation is d one,
the distance to the star we did this for serious,
serious is one of the closest stars.
It's three parsecs away.
Most of the center of the Galaxy is 8,000 parsecs away.
So if you take a typical star in our gala,
the galaxy,
this number isn't going to be three.
It's going to be 8,000.
And this number isn't going to be three.
It's going to be,
uh,
something like one,
one,
1000th of an arc second.
And the space telescope scatters light over tenths of seconds.
So you're,
you're factors of a hundred,
uh,
buried inside the light coming from that star.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
that's why you don't care about more than one digit.
In fact,
you probably don't even care about anything other than the exponent of this
answer because why are you doing this problem?
You're doing this problem to figure out whether it's plausible to think that you
might be able to see a planet as a separate dot separate from the star.
And the fact that your answer comes out in arc seconds or fractions of an arc
second tells you everything you need to know.
You don't need any more decimal places to realize that the idea of looking up
and seeing a planet is going to fail.
So that's not the way that we're going to find planets.
Uh,
so we have to come up with some different scheme a,
and that's what we're going to talk about on Tuesday.
Thanks.